[Musica]
non è così potente la musica
cresce nella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fari j
è qui con me c'è il mio amico giorgio
siccome su trevi a quiz è pieno zeppo di
domande su di me siccome non ha non ha
senso che io faccia dei quiz su di me ho
deciso di far fare un quiz su di me a un
mio amico che in questo caso è lui per
vedere se azzecca qualcosa visto che
secondo me non azzecca rai un cazzo
prove ti piace giocare a trivigliano
grazie eccolo qua parigi tv tutto tuo
mai mai mai quando risale su primocanale
situazioni sono io qua guadagna ogni
volta che sbagliano scappellotto ed
aiutare val padana ciao amici da quando
da ieri e cosa fai a saperlo se ti
cambiamo amico prendi la vicina additivo
quante volte favia fatto papato ha fatto
un video insieme a un altro youtube per
me non so più di 5 con un'idea sta
scadendo il tempo 77 non uccise dai mi
fate un pò 5575 799 da quando sei così
sociale da quando ciao amici come te
porca [ __ ]
sai un cazzo non sai un cazzo vediamo in
un blog ha rinunciato a mettersi le sue
magliette allora come si è vestito dai
la sai questa minchia come fai non
saperla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questi ti voglio carico di che colore
era la scatola che gli arrivate dal
giappone il 13 8 6 recente ma che ora è
recente la scatola giapponese come la
vedrei c
giallo a 75 forma cinese i giapponesi
sono cinesi
di cosa ha paura dai vabbè quasi tutto
ma vero problema è troppo pagine ente di
tutto dal bullo questi non hanno fiducia
in me
in quanti episodi ha finito a dai quei
tanti sinai questa mi faccio e io ne sei
sicuro sia con tesoro da 88 non nessuno
lettera di più te l'ho detto che erano
di più
l'ultimo paio di corner anno fa al
vicolo cosa ha mangiato stamattina e noi
c'è un quiz su di te cosa ordina durante
certi video su 60 secondi ci si sa è un
reato cosa mangio io sono a investissimo
di sì sì sì e pizza pizza com'è chiamato
il cubo di geometri dash gianfrancesco
ei chiari come sei skillato che sarà
difficile questo raramente lipari gli
altri non troppo normali poi è il suo
pokémon più forte non è pentolaio st
vanden borre on live isto stamattina ai
vapori non ci credo fa mi ha fatto il
mio quiz cosa tanto punto punto clicca
non ci credo farvi ha fatto il mio qui
solamente sei tutto lo stai facendo il
lungo lo sto facendo io sto facendo
niente
cosa sui fornelli in questo momento il
crodino
non so però non è che ti hanno regalato
di me l'ha regalato lui che tradotti
grazie è il regalo più bello della
storia
questo vale un bonus per una domanda
chiedilo aiuto la famiglia ha portato
gta sul canale non ha fatto s'era fatto
gravissimo
come ha scoperto google feud tc city per
straniero 10 siri più strano è vero come
giocatori the terrorist è spuntato il
tuo figlio c'è mai stata un'esplosione
su un suo video bene
la risposta potrebbe essere ben bene
comunque se c'è qualcosa che è sposati
fuori quella roba in svolge amica ma la
mia ci sono ancora masulli corriamo
oriani verga che cazzo ne sa quale
speciale iscritti ha fatto drom ilike e
non so perché il mio speciale più
conosciuto era tipo 15.045 milan ero
alto dai non era altro 45 milioni
favi quanti video ha fatto suoi i voli
capo ii tv2
secondo me mi ricordo secondo me di più
secondo me erano più di 11 specie a una
banda una tale a natale sicuro meno
regolari le due sicuro perché li ho
fatti come speciale di mykonos ho fatto
un quarto
allora io mi fido di te di parto è
sopravvissuto di me non ho detto sopra
del 4 a risponderne e un aiuto reale la
madre di che non ti è venuto dura
guardano e si trovava è felice in un
fotomontaggio che ha fatto bene in quale
episodio la vj afferma che c'è dio iscri
prestare tutta questa è difficilissima
terzo perché vado quando ha fatto un
raduno yara è giocato ho fatto raduno io
state 5 agosto
no 27 giu
un altro quante challenge ha fatto
felice in compagnia dei mail allora
nesquik challenge poi quella che hanno
fucka valore hanno due cross bar 34 con
suri quella del mangiare lo schifo e
ieri è uscita una di sasha per
sicuramente non olio dalle prigioni di
umanità saprà sicuramente non è un
giorno su 24 mi dai ragionamenti c'era
il pavè sapeva già e cioè lunga su just
dance 4 chi canta la canzone durante la
quale fa vj ha sostituito l'ultima
parola il ritornello con il suo nome non
ho capito un cazzo coroni farle ed è
vero che mi faccia e vero mito
incredibile va ci ha ricordato lui che
guarda video di just dance del raparo
quanti episodi ha fatto fa vige di tomb
raider aerei d'ombra e 11 fatto uno poi
non sono riuscite andare avanti qual è
stata la causa del gesto che fa vj ha
tenuto per qualche settimana
e poi non mi ricordo non è che dove
cazzo ha fatto a chiudermi il pollice
questo nello sportello come si chiama il
pesce che lorenzo fa riceveva da piccolo
questa scelta
io metterei giorgio andrea il piccolo
andrea al triplo numeri 10 2 pescina
romeo gigli romeo giulietta si sono
suicidati loro oggi 13 agosto 2016
proprio oggi quanti video al canale di
famiglie ma io come cazzo faccio mai
fatto che succede mille qualche giorno
fa quindi 1013 gallori nei cassetti 5
facciamo un paio di quiz randò mitch
così a meno
2 dovremo fare in mezzo cervello cosa
vuoi fare serie a di calcio te neintendi
per da sabri game twilight saga
quella che ti potevi stupire su twilight
saga ha deciso due ragazzi a chi è più
forte nella famiglia cullen juster
carlisle m
chi cazzo m mai non era il parka [ __ ]
non la sapevo questa è buona che la
prima era riscaldamento che cosa devono
i vampire per questa difficile stucchi
questo guarda succo di arancia tacendo
pamina ci è indispensabile prima pista
quando è nata bella minchia va bene
arresti magma ragazzini allora è più
vecchie di noi
complimenti bravissimo ottima deduzione
88 88 che era porca continua il dialogo
tu sei indistruttibile non sono solo un
peso anche ricordato come anche chiamata
renesmee preme no bensì della saga james
non si gioca al cibo aro loro moto va
bene ragazzi è stato accolto studenti si
è divertito avanti gli ho vinto un
cuscino ricordatevi che i vampiri bevono
il succo di arancia forte tre ragazzi
spero che dite vi sia piaciuto che con
quello che ha bisogno ringrazio giorgio
usa questo per chiudere usa questo
perché 7 perugino ma no devi prenderlo
al volo seguito il documento e non mi
piace anche a me di facebook e con un
team avrà la descrizione righe 6
skillato 7 reti sky tv ci mettiamo
prossimo video bella ragazzi cosa